hello and welcome to the shaky science
show so another week another video and
this time I'm taking on the challenge to
provide 53 facts about p53 now there are
definitely more than 53 things to say
about p53 but I thought it was quite a
catchy title so let's get going with it
so p53 is encoded by the gene tp53 and
is found on chromosome 17 on the p arm
at location thirteen point one more than
50% of tumors have mutations at this
locus making it the most common genetic
offense in cancer and so the gene tp53
encodes the sequence for the protein p53
so now about the protein itself so p53
is a protein that has an acidic
n-terminal transactivation domain it has
a protein rich domain a
sequence-specific dna-binding domain and
a localization domain and the basic C
terminal regulatory the name and that
predominant function of p53 is a
transcription factor a protein that
controls rates of transcription of other
genes and it needs that DNA binding
domain to be able to bind upstream of
these genes and so p53 does this as a
home a tetraman and so p53 is a very
famous protein with as famous as
proteins can guards with over ninety
seven thousand citations and p53 was
first identified by having abundant
levels and tumors and so it was thought
to be a selling Lanka gene but this
turned out to be wrong because
expression of wild-type p53 in
colorectal cancer cells actually
inhibited their growth p53 is in fact a
tumor suppressor and it's often referred
to as the guardian of the genome however
if both type p53 is expressed in benign
tumor cells then there is no group
suppressors effects but nonetheless
people who have germline mutations in
p53 and haffley form any syndrome are
predisposed to getting a wide range of
different cancers
so how was p53 acting as a tumor
suppressor whoa the protein is activated
in response to a variety of conditions
such as DNA damage hypoxia and unco gene
activation and once p53
it's fated it can inhibit cell cycle
progression it can induce cellular
senescence and it could also cause
apoptosis which is a form of cell death
and hence these can prevent cancer cells
from replicating so given p53 is
important it's not surprising that it's
tightly regulated and so one way that
p53 is regulated is through its
degradation and say p53 is quite a short
half-life and it is degraded pretty much
as soon as it's synthesized by an e3
vixen I gaze called em DMT and this
function can also be suppressed by the
sv40 large t antigen and by the and by
the human papilloma virus ethics as a
p53 binds with same response elements in
DNA so it is interesting that many of
the missense mutations in cancer are in
the DNA binding domain 6 mutations in
particular are quite common and are
called hotspot mutations these includes
arginine 175 glycine 2 4 5 are 24 8
arginine t49 arginine G 7 3 are 13 to 18
and since p53 accident HMO the mutants
can have dominant negative effects on
the ball type protein and it can also
cause the proteins go into these super
mutants aggregates and it's also thought
that these mutants have a longer
half-life but as important to remember
that not all p53 mutants are created
equal and some of the mutations are
considered gain-of-function since they
have independent effects of the
wild-type protein so some of these gain
of functions includes the gain of
function p53 interacting with other
cellular proteins it can involve p53 up
regulating novel target genes that isn't
bunch it beforehand
the mutants may show structure specific
DNA binding they could also interact
with alternative transcription factors
and help out with that transcription
regulation or it could also prevent the
activity of the p53 related proteins
P 63 and P 73 for how the different
mutations actually having an impact
so the missense mutations come in split
into two categories either DNA binding
mutations or conformational mutations
that so a corona DNA binding domain but
affect the structure of the domain but
there are still important residues in
the other domains of p53 including four
key hydrophobic residues in the tab and
p53 doesn't just find double-stranded
DNA it can also bind single-stranded DNA
secondary DNA structure it can bind to
mismatched bases and DNA bulges the last
two which are kind of useful in its
response in DNA damage and this is
thought the c-terminal domain and p53
mediates this non sequence-specific
binding on p53 and although I've already
mentioned this the p53 is actually under
tight regulation and say when it up
regulates mdm2
which causes the p53 degradation it
creates a negative feedback loop and so
if my calculations are correct this
should be the final fact one of the
wasn't really a fad this one one of the
key important questions we kind of want
to understand is chemic target p53 or
its downstream mediators to be able to
use it for clinical treatments so yeah
hey we made it so 53 well I say we I
technically that the hard work you just
got to listen to it but anyway there are
definitely more than 53 facts out there
that p53 but hopefully this was a good
introduction so thank you for listening